you'll be spicehead upon its release the
Dark Knight Returns changed the
landscape of comics it offered a greatly
take on the Caped Crusader that was a
complete polar opposite to the 1966 show
before this book Batman was regarded as
a con by the public consciousness a
lovable jock that provided comedic
relief on a Saturday morning it was a
far cry from the dark look at crime that
the character had once been and the Dark
Knight Returns restored the character to
the status quo whilst deconstructing
comics in the process but does it still
stand up it's been 30 years since its
release and whilst it is one of my
favorite graphic novels of all time even
I can admit that it's not perfect tastes
change in the scrutiny that we now hold
the modern comics may shine this in a
poor light there's also the fact that
Frank Miller as when absolutely proper
mental is this book a product of its
time or is it still one of the best ever
that's what I'm here to find out so
without further ado let's dive into my
Dark Knight Returns review the book
opens I'm Bruce Wayne racing to his
death in Gotham's annuals master race
that's not fun for the dog well it is a
pun for the Dark Knight 3 but it does
stop with M shakes after giving up the
mantle of Batman to use adjacent odds
death he feels like a lost man similar
to astronauts who become alcoholics
after returning to earth he's lost the
purpose that gave him life he achieved
greatness but it was a curse nothing
matches up to being the Dark Knight and
now he seeks a glorious death at every
opportunity this was completely
groundbreaking for the time prior to
this we rarely ever saw an old superhero
immortalized through the pages of the
comics superheroes were supposed to be
young men
what the decade constantly in the
thirties Batman hadn't aged since the
nineteen thirties this book shook up
that notion the young Batman was no more
and all that was left was a cold beaten
shell of a man I absolutely love this
twist on the character it's a true
deconstruction of the genre that other
leaves went on to influence things like
Metal Gear Solid 4 Rambo Unforgiven less
goes on it's my preferred version of
Batman it's easy to see why teensy have
used this as a springboard for the new
movie universe Batman's gritty grumpier
is like Gran Torino times 400 I think
this is one of the main selling points
of the character in this boot what's
fascinating about this opening race is
how well it works metaphorically in
telling the tale of Bruce's journey
through the booth I never really noticed
it till now but it really works
the card is what it's not supposed to it
has a mind of its own
it's almost forced to be put down quit
the race but that engine argues back
Bruce says it would be a good death but
not good enough as he crosses the finish
line the news reports that it's a
flaming coffin for Bruce Wayne or so
everyone thought this is an outstanding
portrayal of Bruce's journey throughout
the booth like the car going out in a
blaze of glory against all those trying
to control it Bruce Wayne sort of packed
the destruction that he barely makes it
through crime is rampant through Gotham
and Bruce cannot take it anymore there's
a calling within him and the return to
the cowl is still as traumatic today as
it was in 1986 to me this has always
been a book about falling off the Hall
getting back on it how many times have
you personally been great at something
and then you've been forced to quit that
feeling of loss that you have towards
being great again never really goes away
it's very deep inside and it's a perfect
summation of Bruce's need to become
Batman once more it's one of the aspects
that makes the character so relatable in
this incarnation and to see him return -
it's a really triumphant moment he dives
into the night Thunder on his back and
it's a really reaffirmed moment that we
all have the ability deep down to be the
person that we once were and wanted to
be his first night back in the role is
highly inspirational and I can't commend
Miller highly enough for how
breathtaking this moment is Harvey
Dent's been cured plastic surgeries
restored his face to what it once was
and this should have restored him
psychologically but is still a bad guy
that everyone loves - hey it's a great
ambiguity in mystery around Harvey's
true intentions throughout this book and
it will definitely be enough to keep the
first-time readers grips asking as a
black mirror I absolutely loved the way
that Miller uses two-face to reflect how
Bruce's it's a real struggle eyes unable
to defeat you can't battle is inner
demons and eventually the Beast Within
is gonna take him down similar to this
the Joker who has been budgeted since
Batman's retirement begins to awaken all
of the Giants have Gotham have they're
calling their purpose that without they
cease to exist and this is what the food
especially food one is about one of the
biggest takes that I've seen sent around
this book is that the Joker is gay
whilst he uses words like darling he
fights Batman in the tunnel of love
there's several innuendos like not
falling asleep on me on you and Batman
can't perform I never really took it to
be intentionally homosexual to me the
joke is actually asexual well swing
pounder Bruno his girlfriend who's very
masculine with them stupid nasty nipples
we never see the to cohabit in the same
space upon release the Joker never 6rl
and she doesn't ever mention and
I actually strive to spring the Joker
from Arkham this signifies to me that
the relationship is completely
superficial the Joker is unable to love
another person in my opinion instead he
loves an idea is chaos embodied Batman
represents order together the to create
a perfect circle of human States
balancing the other perfectly
Batman completes the Joker but that
doesn't mean that the Joker loves him in
a traditional sense at least he merely
requires him to exist the same way that
humans depend on oxygen but we don't
love oxygen Joker depends on order oh he
doesn't love Batman he's a wicked and
twisted being it feels almost no human
emotion and it seems unconventional for
the Joker to experience the love in my
eyes especially when it's such a
positive human emotion so I simply
missed having this emotional attachment
I'm open to the fact that I'm wrong
though or if you think I'm wrong comment
below that's the perfect way to derail
my entire argument book 1 ends on Harvey
Dent attempting to ransom Gotham by
threatening to blow up the two towers
this might be controversial in today's
eyes due to 9/11 it certainly acts as a
great end to the first issue one thing I
didn't like about the animated movie was
that it implied that Harvey Dent was on
a suicide mission which I really don't
take from reading the book to me I see
it as the Toyman who built the bomb
deliberately sabotage them so they
couldn't be deactivated this is implied
by his meeting with the Joker who begins
questioning the toyman's use of the
bombs Harvey isn't suicidal to me in
fact he totally accepts two ears and
plays along with it and really embraces
the two-faced persona that we see in
this booth knowing that he's unable to
escape his fate much like Batman it's a
great closer to book 1 and this works
perfectly as an opening issue on book
one's own mirror I want to score a
perfect 10 out of 10 the plot and
characters are very
developed even by today's standards and
it still feels very ahead of the curve
and its ideas Miller's are also very
good in this issue it's definitely some
of the best each put on page so I
recommend you pick it up just to read
this issue alone thanks for checking out
my review of the Dark Knight Returns
with one I'll be back with my follow-up
review of the tomb
I'm doing this series as a build-up to
review in the dark my three the master
race so make sure you subscribe to my
channel and keep up to date
I'm also on patreon now which is linked
in the description I've got my loads of
books that I've got a review anything
that you can donate really helps towards
purchasing though so your pledge can
make a huge difference thank you very
much take care
[Music]